I know who Camilla really really does
love though in a total fangirl way
17-year old music sensation Billy Eilish
and Camilla is not the only one so there
is the what I'm calling Billy's
Hollywood Stan Club
I love Camilla so much she's a perfect
knows she really does she was really a
little sister and her sister started
sobbing cuz I mean it was like insane I
was like your sisters like a Baio though
are you crying for me like that Katy
Perry in a bucket had beings like her
don't enter our orbit often that's super
sweet and Orlando Bloom just smiling
that is a little wifey people in the
world are speculating that you and Demi
lavato are collaborating because you
have the same hair color right now she's
so incredibly talented yeah but I don't
think I don't think she has my hair wait
can I say yeah see oh so it's like the
option she has the opposite which could
be cool in a music video yeah okay duh
there are so many reasons millions are
obsessed with Billy of course her music
she's got her own sense of style and
she's always unfiltered thank Yeller
reaching a little bit we got the
exclusive invite to Billy's intimate
performance alongside her brother
Phineas at the Grammy Museum what's cool
this 17 year old could soon be the
youngest person ever to win the big four
at the Grammys sometimes I talk with
people in there like I've been
practicing my Grammy speech since I was
a kid and I knew that it was coming no
no really people say that I think it's
so weird when people think they're gonna
be huge god that's so weird
I never in a million years would've
thought this would happen like I'm only
grateful for it for real
[Music]
[Applause]